In all,
thanks for allowing me,
uh,
to announce it.
Indeed,
I will lead this list
for the European elections next June,
and I would like to thank Éric Zemmour for
his confidence.
I am happy to work with him,
in complementarity,
he who will be our natural candidate,
of course,
for the elections
ofdeux-mille-vingt-sept.
the opportunity to gather right-wing voters
around a great battle,
uh,
and I weigh my words,
which, uh.
And civilizational,
which is historical and vital,
which is that of The Defense of Our Identity,
our culture,
of our values
that are today
threatened by migration assumption
and by Islamization.
Yes, so what.
Come on, play!